يسابق البنك المركزي الاثيوبي الزمنى
لاستكمال قانون تنظيم البنوك الاجنبيه بعد
موافقه مجلس الوزراء على السماح بعملها في
البلاد بعد قرابه اربعه عقود من الحظر
خطوه اعتبرت نقله نوعيه في مسار الاصلاح
الاقتصادي وتعزيز كفاءه الاقطاع المالي
بحسب مسؤولين يوجبان
ماذا فعلنا للسماح للبنوك الاجنبيه هو
استكمال نقص البنوك المحليه في المنتجات
او الخدمات او المهارات وجود البنوك
الاجنبيه سينقل لنا الخبرات ويعزز التقنيه
ويربط اقتصادنا بالسوق الدوليه
العالمي وتلبيه رغبات العملاء جميعا
هذا الطموح لم يخلو من مخاوف لدى البنوك
المحليه سيام التي تاسست خلال العامين
الماضيين والبالغ عددها 10 بنوك حيث يقول
مراقبون ان دخول البنوك الاجنبيه سيخل
بمبدا المنافسه المتكافئه الذي ضل سعيدا
لعقود طويله بحكم الحذر وان البنوك
المحليه اقل قدره وخبره من ان تنافس
البنوك الاجنبيه
هو ان دخول البنوك الاجنبيه السوق
المصرفيه بوضعها الحالي قد تطرد بعض
البنوك المحليه من السوق والحل من وجهه
نظري يكون في تاخير تنفيذ هذا القرار حتى
تستعد البنوك المحليه بالشكل المطلوب او
ان تعتمد هذه البنوك على الاندماج لتكوين
كيانات كبيره قادره على المنافسه
في اثيوبيا 30 مصرفا خاصا باجماله رؤوس
اموال تبلغ التريليونين و 400 مليار بر
اثيوبي تعادل نحو 45 مليار دولار و9 هذه
المصارف وجاهده لزياده راس المال للوفاء
بمتطلبات البنك المركزي بعد ان امهلها
اربع سنوات
لمضاعفته
يتاهب القطاع المصرفي في اثيوبيا لمرحله
جديده فالوافد الاجنبي سيعيد تشكيل خريطه
المنافسه حول المنتجات والخدمات وبعيدا عن
الجدري الدائر فان المحددات الاساسيه
للربح والخساره تقدر على اساس القيمه
المضافه للاقتصاد والمواطنين في نهايه
المطاف حسن الرزاق الجزيره اديس ابابا